débloquera chose a commenté la de 60 ans
c'est par cette photo d'aujourd'hui
jacqueline et lucien se sont rencontrés
en 1951
mais au début ce n'était pas forcément
gagné c'est un petit bal de quartier rue
des graviers à paris dans le 3e
arrondissement
et puis non la soirée de sable dans les
clous très bien ce soir je l'a
raccompagné la nuit terrés du temps donc
c'était juste à côté si vous voulez et
bien élevé j'ai voulu faire un bisou
mais bon bisous séoul et elle n'a pas
voulu genève ou bâle pas pour vivre ça
va pas trop chercher porter comme on dit
mais qui allait vraiment pas que ça ne
l'a pas trouvé persévérant lucientes ont
à nouveau la semaine suivante
et c'est le début d'une longue relation
ils se marient à paris le 16 mars 1957
nous avons voulu aller couper ce que je
vous dis là elle s'appelle de la nuit de
noces m'a dit d'aller laver l'eau 30 ans
à gérer en plus de leur vie intime leur
vie professionnelle se fait-elle aussi
main dans la main ils exercent ensemble
la profession de charcutier leurs
secrets rsl 7 cm avec l'âge ça change
des sentiments ils sont toujours
amoureusement si vous voulez mais le
plus au truc c'est de ne pas me pouvoir
se passer l'un de l'autre pour célébrer
leur union le couple a fêté en mars ses
noces de diamant en mairie de maurepas
une cérémonie émouvante
entourés de leurs enfants et même
arrière petits enfants jacqueline et
lucien habite la ville depuis 1978
le maire leur a écrit un poème doit
s'entendre main dans la main
amoureux comme des galibots de du
quotidien chasse des petits voiliers
s'était bel image soit 50 ans en arrière
et voyez comme elle me regarde je peux
encore la regarder comme ça où il est
par des yeux mais je t'aime mon coeur
c'est vrai à 84 ans jacqueline et lucien
poursuivre leur route à 2 jusqu'à ce que
la mort les sépare